[Music]
natural disasters can be completely
unpredictable and cause damage worth
billions of dollars but there are some
things that are so indestructible they
can't even be damaged by a hurricane
wait until you see the Texan house that
was able to stand alone in the midst of
the Hurricane Ike destruction in 2008 if
you're new here make sure to subscribe
to our channel to never miss a video and
don't forget to give us a big thumbs up
today we're discussing things hurricanes
cannot destroy Houston highways
hurricanes can range from having a minor
or a severe impact on the city depending
on the location and other elements and
although there are ways to prepare for
the impact of a hurricane
you never know the damage and the
severity will have on your immediate
area on August 25th 2017 Houston was hit
by a category 4 hurricane called Harvey
a category 4 hurricane is known to cause
significant damage to properties animals
and of course people damage to large
structures can be expected along with
power outages and water shortages that
can last from a few weeks to a few
months while many properties did not
manage to survive Harvey's impact there
is a structure that managed to stay
unharmed the design of the Houston
highways survived and even though the
roads were completely submerged in water
as the hurricane continued to destroy
the city you can check out pictures at
the interstate 10 as it turned into an
ocean but you can see that the structure
remained intact as the hurricane made
its way through the area and flooded the
highways as well as the rest of the city
the highways survived the damage as of
September 2017 the city is now
recovering from the severe damage and
mourning the lives that were lost to
hurricane Harvey Spaulding
Rehabilitation Hospital in the case of a
hurricane hospitals have a hard job when
it comes to keeping all their patients
safe while making sure they're also
receiving everything they need to
recover after Spaulding Rehabilitation
Hospital was hit by Hurricane Katrina in
2005
it took an innovative approach to
prepare for any future disasters that
might take place and made sure its
patients can be safe at all times in
2013 the city introduced a brand new
building that looks completely prepared
for climate change and hurricanes to
start it off the design of the building
makes
that all primary electrical services are
located on the rooftop to make sure the
building's electricity does not get
affected by the floods the electricity
itself is powered by a fuel pump which
is secured by a flood proof vault the
actual ground floor is elevated by 2.5
feet which protects the hospital from
any potential flooding even the outside
of the place has landscape walls which
act like a reef in the event of a storm
all of these precautions ensure that the
building can still function and the
patients can still be taken care of
during a natural disaster the building
looks pretty solid and definitely ready
to protect itself and its patients
during a hurricane seems like the
Spaulding Rehabilitation Hospital truly
is safe and ready for hurricanes this
ferry we often see the shocking
aftermath of cities being hit by a
high-level hurricane many of the
buildings end up completely destroyed or
flooded and the damage can cost the city
billions of dollars but sometimes
depending on the circumstances larger
ships and boats can survive natural
disasters when northern Japan was hit by
an a tsunami following an earthquake in
2011 it left one of the most devastating
damages on the seaside cities with many
buildings that ended up being destroyed
it's hard to believe that this ferry
remains completely undisturbed even
though it's positioned on top of the
building and clearly went through some
damage you can clearly see the table and
chairs on the deck being completely
intact boats are very much at nature's
mercy when coming in contact with strong
weather conditions but this ferry was
able to survive the damages of a strong
earthquake along with the tsunami
following afterward while many smaller
and weaker boats and ships aren't as
lucky when it comes to natural disasters
large ferries and cruise ships can
definitely survive a tsunami especially
if they're docked and tied with extra
strong materials while the strong waves
could potentially knock the ship against
the pier the ship structure would most
likely survive the Hurricanes impact of
course this also depends on the severity
of the tsunami as well as the position
of the ship itself Sir Richard Branson
although he's definitely not
indestructible like some of the houses
and other buildings were mentioning in
this video it's worthy to mention how
the business tycoon survived the 2017
hurricane Irma as it made its way across
the Caribbean and Florida at the time of
the hurricane Sir Richard Branson
located on his private island in the
Caribbean despite knowing that the
hurricane will directly impact the
island and the surrounding area the
businessman decided to stay put with his
family knowing they will most likely
stay unharmed there the family spent the
night in their wine cellar where they
experienced a night of howling wind and
rain although he considered this to be a
fun sleepover it's safe to say that the
somewhat indestructible Sir Richard
Branson could face a different fate had
it not been for the sturdy wine cellar
which in his words would be running out
of wine by the time the storm would
subside although the rest of his private
island was pretty much destroyed by the
hurricane the wine cellar remained
intact it's important to note that this
is not always the case when it comes to
wine cellars as they could be the
victims of potential flooding with no
escape Sir Richard Branson might be an
indestructible business tycoon but we
have to admit he was pretty lucky in
this situation this standalone house no
this is not a photo shop but we can
assume that these houses got extremely
lucky when it came to avoiding potential
hurricane disasters one such was this
lucky house that survived the rage of
the 2008 Hurricane Ike which destroyed a
large portion of Southeast Texas and
caused 37.6 billion dollars worth of
damage
soon after the incredible images of the
last house standing went viral the house
is seen built at a higher level but
there is a good reason behind it the
people who lived here have already faced
a natural disaster that costs them their
previous home the owners of the house
Warren and Pam Adams previously lost a
home on the same lot to the 2005
Hurricane Rita the home was then
completely rebuilt but nothing could
prepare them for the destructive forces
of Hurricane Ike just three years later
while their home along with a couple of
other ones looked completely intact and
unaffected by the hurricane
the couple reported that it's not
inhabitable as the flood damaged most of
the rooms along with the appliances even
though the house was built 22 feet above
the normal sea level the flood still
managed to completely destroy the
interior but although the hurricane
damaged the interior of the house it is
still extraordinary that the exterior
remained completely intact and that's it
for ten things hurricanes cannot destroy
for more videos like this one check out
15 random acts of vandalism that are
your genius see you next time
[Music]